you're sure it's this fine club hey can
I say something this is taric's gym yep
can I say some what's up my heart don't
even those shirts can I say side train
on this channel hey I'm gonna dump in
your mouth can I say something god man
well we're shooting yesterday with our
friend Aubrey Marcus the Restonic crew
at the twins shout to the twins LSU
Tigers shouting it's big the twins the
big Victor twins you would not shut the
[ __ ] up about going to special salons
house I'm talking dude I'm just friends
you what you would have thought Brian
was a 21 year old you asked me what I
did wrong we can do s now in any time
I'd like no slide post time I say hey
calm Sylvester bro sorry's in front of
mine Oh mr. Sloane
he's friendly it's like posted a video
look I'm a beef did I hang out at his
house with Arnold Schwarzenegger and Al
Pacino and and Dolph Lundgren yeah
did I not some other people yeah was I
was Sly Stallone sure now did his living
room smell like testosterone and protein
parts and death uh-huh the I tell you so
with the one thing about him over
anything else what was the one thing
that surprised me he's [ __ ] hilarious
he's [ __ ] hilarious hey I like he's
got the best sense of humor which I
never knew I didn't know his nut um what
else I know but he tells stories and I
was like I said to Frank Grillo I go
dude he's [ __ ] hilarious
because I know he's got a great sense of
humor he tells [ __ ] hilarious stories
so that was really cool and you guys
were over there
to watch the fights yes and do they do
they like you if the unboxing video yes
of course it was in the other in the in
the other room the screening room
watching the UFC we were watching the
boxing but they had the wave for the
boxing who they'll have the UFC was done
but anyway so we were running back and
forth and then we you know but it was
just really interesting I will say this
is all sacis the funniest
oh yeah why the video and then other
ones you says his comment mine shows
this second time
this is me and Frank grilling over Al
Pacino now please read will sasso scam
me Oh just break on there's more screen
time in this Instagram post than he does
[Laughter]
like [ __ ] Callen come on
yeah Callen James gun too now I will say
this about his house and and a lot of
you are young and you're gonna be like
Brian and this is not a responsible
familiar thing for me to say but I want
to say it out loud say it's about his
house money buys happiness I said it out
loud did Sylvester seem happy yeah he
did yeah he did beautiful family he's
got a gorgeous got three gorgeous
daughters there's holler at me he's got
a his wife is my age and couldn't look
better she looks like if his wife walked
into a [ __ ] bar research in if his
wife walked into a [ __ ] bar that's
her there oh that's his daughter if his
wife walked into a bar with thirty year
olds they she everybody would be trying
to pick her up she's sick hot get his
daughter's yeah and his daughters are
great his daughters are [ __ ] great
they're just good girls I that was the
crazy thing as they grew up like royalty
and their normal their normal human
beings I won't get out there nuts
um but Arnold was cool too yeah
yadi kept oh come on do it well he's he
is that his daughter just look up oh
yeah tell between the Dodgers in the
month we're all seeing that eating in
Arnold comes and goes look at these
criminals this criminal is this is where
all the riffraff Arnold was down because
movie bombed
well I knew until then I didn't care
well he didn't know until the next day
so yeah there there you go there are the
girls come on
the man's tongue alright by himself he's
done alright bill birnes there bill burr
was there and I so I walk in and sly is
smoking a cigar with Bill understand
they're talking I walk in hey bill goes
hey what's up and burr after an hour cuz
like it's Al Pacino you understand I
grew up with these guys they're part of
my history
what would it's not it's not a little
thing for me I it's Al Pacino it's so
vest
it's all scores there it from me there
wasn't when you talk about why'd you
become an actor
you got to include you have to put out
Sylvester Stallone in Rocky yeah and and
you have to put Al Pacino in there as
some of the biggest influences of my
life and some of the reasons I got into
this [ __ ] business in the first place
so I'm looking at people that are part
of my history and and and their all-time
greats so at one point Arnold and I
think sly talking Al Pacino's over there
and I'm just kind of standing there and
I'm like looking at this my history and
I'm looking on and Bill Brock come over
to sit down and Bill burr goes hey
you've been here over an hour get over
it already
all right let's get over it I know tell
me about it even he's the same way you
know Bill's pretty famous now but it's
that doesn't matter you're like [ __ ]
he's part of our there's there's so much
of a part of our childhood then you're
you're at their house it's so but guess
what they are just like us regular dudes
funny silly geese all about laughing he
has all three girls yeah a couple things
you don't know about sly a couple things
we should talk about with sly hell of a
painter hell of a painter which I was
blown away by he can really paint and
he's a professional horseman
professional grew up on horseback polo
pony and competed on a high level which
I didn't know so I'm still making the
[ __ ] rainbows in the last one I don't
know when the new one comes out but the
one before that was pretty good violin
it's fun oh yeah any good well he stayed
relevant since 1905 when him is not
relevant since 1975 dude when him and
Arnold did that escape the prison movie
good movie man hell yeah he's something
else it seems like he's got really good
friendships and I think it comes from
having a good family anyway yeah it's
been in the business for so I anyway
guys if you need me on Saturdays fight
nights I'll probably over at my friend's
house cool cool
is that Antonio Banderas yeah man time
gets us all [ __ ] time gets us this Oh
does the oven Instagram page and and
nobody's mounting a stronger challenge
to time than our
then then our boy Stallone but it gets
us off loans giving up the fight
yeah
he's getting up was he second elaborado
yeah he's got to be 60 something right
how old is he he looks pretty good yeah
that's his fan there I don't think so
it's his daughter 59 mm-hmm
only seven years old and you'd be okay
okay well that'll be mean that will be
you it's fun though dude may be fun when
you look like that yeah wanna me yeah
it's got guys in shape guys got a
[ __ ] he's got some forearms gigantic
yeah yeah he's veiny dude he's fainting
and I gotta get a little more veining
dude
you're probably the only guy in that
room not on trt think about it
well Pacino's not no Pacino's nah but
that's it everyone else juice to the
gills probably and I celebrate it yeah
probably right I'd love to talk about
Tod yeah well whatever he's doing it
works yeah dude you're Rambo you gotta
be on you can't let yourself go
I mean he's nothing more but he just
stays in shape look at that I want to
kind of work out he's doing uh I was
pretty jacked to those for his age you
never stopped he's never stopped working
out he looks great
well old Marlins gotta like his belly is
so flat like I said he's walks and he's
got a blazer on but you can see he's
just keeps it no there's a picture I'm
in like a [ __ ] soon gun he's pretty
[ __ ] but how old is he Arnold
yeah what's nod what sly 70 wattle or 73
with a life Arnold come on an immigrant
the two-time governor of California 72
years old
it's like Trump almost right I have I
have to tell you that for me when i when
i and i maybe I'm wrong when I see older
dudes who do TRT and I see anybody does
TRT even like they start in their
forties I think it ages you I I noticed
keep the same energy when you go to
stones house now [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
well I think it's the same energy you
have right now
he's pretty to faith so when you go over
there right
you guys look grave who said that you
know they do look great and Sloane looks
great yeah but that's from working out
probably eats like a [ __ ] Spartan and
you know it's a lifetime of close to the
bone
you know but TR t those guys are on John
same energy keep the same energy talking
all this [ __ ] but over there sucking the
boys off tell you the toughest guy in
that room was who is the toughest guy in
that room by far
who'd be who beats up everybody in that
room money's Brian bill burr no bill
burr [ __ ] mercenaire bill burr it's a
comic stuff okay you go shut up good
comic shut up man key good bill burr al
pacino hey before you keep it [ __ ]
none of your tough but keep going haqiqa
Dober Al Pacino Frank Grillo there uh
and Dolph
we've got Dolph Lundgren I don't know
dolf's background keep going so dummy up
his everybo six five don't care about
size Berta he's every bit he's Swedish
knees he care if he's every bit as
probably weighs if you look at his hands
his head
probably weighs at least two 3562 - he's
not six - I was standing next to him he
sees that's hilarious that one it says
he's only 62 Oh
62 yeah but when he was younger and he's
still in great shape
I mean he's a [ __ ] house and he was
also European kickboxing champion you
know look at him when he's younger he's
all dog scroll up chin there it is
he showed some interest drumming he took
up karate at age 10 began lifting
weights
oh he's on the karate team you want to
turn him in when he was only a green
belt he won the European Championships
and that heavyweight term in Australia
graduated with a chemical engineering in
karate or was it kickboxing is a big
diff karate kill chicken karate kick in
is they actually do kick and punch they
actually spar there could been a couple
guys in UFC early time who are killing
karate guys so you want to tournament
big run guy very big strong athletic guy
very strong like like like I died with
you easy easy that's a big guy mmm you
know and an athletic but I'm four five
years in karate look at him what he's
younger for a second take a look at mine
is younger Yeah right here or younger
yeah I mean he's a big 200 and [ __ ] 35
pound guy big guy you know that that's a
lot of then and athletic looking at
their younger come in you know from the
rest of us as regular guys that's a big
dude it just did a lot of body then move
why you
oh what's the point he's just a big dude
Sandi's the self he's probably the most
athletic guy in the room
definitely aesthetic Grace Jones you're
saying if like a fight broke out with
all yeah I think he's gonna he's got a
head this pig I mean he's just safe he's
angry he's just a different weight class
well hope he doesn't fight man tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]